in afghanistan kabul's main airport is
open to commercial flights once again
dozens of people including at least 21
u.s citizens and green card holders left
on this fight yesterday but there are
new signs of the taliban clamping down
charlie daggett is just over the border
in pakistan our captures our cameras
rather captured armed members of the
taliban patrolling the streets right
next to people who are desperate to
leave charlie good morning
good morning we're at the tour gum
crossing with pakistan on that side and
that is afghanistan on that side we've
got taliban flags flying high taliban
members who are now guarding this border
crossing there are hundreds of people
who are trying to get out some in need
of urgent medical attention and they're
being stopped not just by the taliban
but by pakistan who don't want to
encourage a huge influx of refugees
until there's a coherent international
plan in place here's just an example of
some of the brutality that they're
leaving behind a couple journalists said
they were beaten badly by the taliban
after covering a women's protest the
taliban have now cracked down on those
protests banning them until further
notice now as the taliban continues to
tighten its grip through intimidation we
can expect more people to try to flood
to the borders even though they're being
discouraged any way they can to get away
from taliban rule
nate charlie dagger in pakistan thank
you